le jeu quand même permettre une vieille
motif qu'ils jouent pas dans la notice
ça serait metal bienvenue à la notice ne
tour d'horizon des jantes et du monde
sportif
à 43 ans tom brady prendre part à un
dizième super bowl soit quatre de plus
que n'importe qui donc comme un bon tome
à prendre ont battu les packers tom
brady et son vieux copain rob gronkowski
ont d'ailleurs repris leur marche un
brin arrogantes au sens de bad boy for
live de viral il ya 2 1 alors qu'on
devait tout aussi qu'il était déjà finie
avant le dernier super bowl avec les
patriots ont trait de khôl et j'ai cessé
de creuser son secteur jeunesse pas se
perdre en paraît 10 et le bidon r'n'b
nord rudy a fait taire encore une fois
tous ces délits graves qui doutent
encore qu'il est le meilleur de
l'histoire si j'étais l'époque à news je
m'assurerai que b les tchèques soient
interdits de voyage en floride pour au
moins deux semaines afin de s'assurer
que ça l'ukraine faute de compliquer et
bâle
la nfl a par ailleurs invité 7500
travailleurs de la santé a assisté en
personne aux matchs entre les box et
litchi au stade de thèmes pas la seule
raison pour laquelle ils font ça c'est
pour permettre à laurent très tardive de
retourner au super bowl
les nouvelles rondelle technologique
micro puce et de la lnh ont été retirés
dès la première semaine d'activités
notamment après que le franc-tireur
ashton matthews se soient plaints que la
rondelle rebondissait après qu'il ait
marqué seulement un but à ses quatre
premiers matches voilà on n'a pas de
l'histoire l'excusent la pop voulait pas
pour nous autres ont été jugées valides
brandon le mieux des rangers n'avait
quant à lui pas vraiment compris que
c'était la première semaine d'activités
parce qu'il s'est sacrifié comme si
c'était un septième match de la coupe
stanley ça peut faire mal
il est clairement le gars qui a absorbé
le plus de coups depuis scott sterling
l'homme nommé la légende
[Applaudissements]
brandon je sais que c'est enfin le mieux
mais gardant pour le reste d'année en
famille c'est l'homme du coup mise en
scène jim green a tout tenté pour
expliquer aux officiels qui ne
s'adressait pas à eux
mais le joueur des warriors de golden
state a été expulsé pour avoir injurié
l'un de ses coéquipiers sur le terrain
la recrue james white semaine c'est les
arbitres de la lnh protéger la même
façon les jeunes joueurs de ce qu'ils
leur crie après pierre legris bois
serait encore à columbus et john
tortorella serait au manitoba et dans le
nord avec les sources par attac a lancé
de 22 92 m l'américain ryan trois heures
a pulvérisé le record du lancer du poids
à l'intérieur
si vous partagez cette vidéo je vais
manger devant vos yeux ébahis ce petit
pois franchement le confinement se
poursuivre pour 72 joueurs de tennis à
melbourne et guido péno on a perdu la
raison comme domaine d'un seul au monde
du show
oh c'est son cas présentement on peut
trouver le temps long confinement
ok moi c'est du solide wyss
à la semaine prochaine merci à tous pour
vos partages ça nous agrément cas à quoi